what do giant squirrels have to do with
norse mythology our last look at thor
love and thunder before the film's
release contains some small details that
may point towards the answer
at the dawn of july the studio dropped a
final trailer just in case anyone forgot
that thor is slated to do glorious
battle with a former batman yes that
means christian bale one week later on
july 8th the blockbuster which also
stars tessa thompson and natalie portman
has released trailer after trailer over
the past few months with the same level
of consistency as an art house film
desperately afraid of under exposure
that's okay though because it looks
great and no one minds seeing more of
portman's ripped biceps
rather contentiously both avengers
infinity war and particularly avengers
end game opted to drag thor through
every possible pain he could experience
and that's after seeing his entire world
wiped out in thor ragnarok plus losing
each of his parents
most of his remaining people were slain
by thanos pre-snap his friend heimdall
was unceremoniously murdered by thanos
and his brother loki was strangled by
thanos
the purple space dictator really had it
out for the thor franchise for some
reason and then the latter film
proceeded to portray his journey through
the aforementioned pain as a joke
because it's apparently hilarious to see
someone turn to food and drink for
emotional support
fortunately thor love and thunder
doesn't seem to be playing the thunder
god's grief for laughs
near the start of the newest trailer
viewers are treated to a somber slide
show of people that thor has lost
including frigger his mother
over the course of these images gore the
god butcher ominously commiserates with
thor acknowledging the true depth of his
loss in addition to this it looks as if
thor is desperately attempting to get
his life together using meditation a
strict workout regimen and other
ostensibly solid coping mechanisms
despite the fact that director taika
waititi is known for trolling anyone and
anything he possibly can it appears as
if he's tackling thor's mental health
with all the severity such a topic
requires
in previous trailers viewers were
treated to the fact that thor is still
clearly in love with jane foster who is
now the mighty thor with her
ridiculously cool shattered meonia that
along with the title of the film has
long suggested that thor's newest movie
will heavily or at least partially
revolve around his swooning heart
in this the most recent trailer there's
a quick glimpse of the two thor's
holding hands well sort of they're
actually doing the holding pinky fingers
thing which is arguably the cutest way
to hold hands since it's in the same
black and white scale that the well
publicized battle with gore is in it's
probably a moment of camaraderie between
the two as they mentally prepare to
fight for their lives after all anyone
known as the god butcher would probably
stir a bit of tension in a pair of
thoughts so it might simply be them
reaching out for some small modicum of
comfort
with that dark thought in mind it's
still an incredibly tender loving
gesture that's rarely seen in cinema let
alone being utilized by shredded norse
deities it's just really really touching
previous love and thunder trailers have
notably played with imagery associated
with idracel the world tree of norse
mythology and this final release again
teases these connections more
specifically there's a shot in the most
recent trailer in which mighty thor
who's holding the lightning bolt of zeus
looks as if she's sharing the bolt's
power she could also be slowly murdering
all those people who's to say the camera
angle viewers get is an overhead shot
that depicts the bolt spreading through
the crowd in an interesting pattern that
kind of looks like the aforementioned
tree a detail that studious fans of
norse mythology have almost certainly
already taken note of to be fair this
particular resemblance could be entirely
unintentional but assuming that she's
sharing power and not doing a murder the
symbolism would be significant
aedrazil is a magic tree that functions
like connective tissue between the
realms one could climb the tree to get
from midgard earth realm to niflheim
loki's original realm provided that
ratataska was cool with this oh you
don't know ratatoskr
that's a giant squirrel beast that
guards iggazel
norse mythology is wild
aside from the squirrelly tangent using
world tree symbology as a visual unifier
is well it's not a deep curse but it's
incredibly interesting
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]